without further ado danny theo
hi
[Applause]
drew
none of that was in the prompter thank
you from the prompter and i speak the
truth all right what are we doing first
well i know you love makeup so we are
going to talk about makeup brushes guys
so if you are not cleaning your makeup
brushes you're basically just reapplying
germs and bacteria right onto your skin
but also we want to be environmentally
friendly and not just constantly replace
them so we're going to show you how to
wash them it's so simple you start with
olive oil
because you want to make sure the
bristles stay nice and soft if you just
wash it with soap and water it gets
really hard so we're going to take the
dish soap pour it into the olive oil
this is going to do all of your brushes
right here
emulsification process emulsified this
is not a salad dressing
it looks like a yummy vinaigrette but
it's not it does
you take your brush this is super dirty
we're gonna put it in here swirl it
around just a little bit
so we're gonna take our beaker
take our brush and watch the magic
happen is this water yeah and you just
put in water in your sink or whatever
and then you swirl it and look how much
comes out
of that brush
look at this look at this
i love you
cheers true
[Laughter]
now oh my god oh and it does it's like
mink it feels so good
okay okay wow now let's talk about
carpets okay
so i feel like carpets are making a huge
comeback in homes don't you feel like i
love a cozy carpet and when you have
kids and pets it's they can smell
whoa right if you don't want like a
machine if you don't go through the
hassle what i like to do is i take a
little sieve just like this and two
simple ingredients so we've got baking
soda and cinnamon cinnamon okay
so these are two things that are great
deodorizers for your carpet so i will
fill up
even a bigger one at home i'll take
baking soda
fill it up right into my container and
then i'll add a big tablespoon of
cinnamon right here and these are two
deodorizers
these are two things that go deep into
the carpet you let it sit for 24 hours
what it's doing it's pulling the excess
moisture it's killing all the germs and
bacteria it's freshening with natural
cinnamon
and then
all right
you've got it you've got a blizzard over
there
it's clean
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
good news i made a terror missile so you
did
you let it sit for 24 hours and then you
just vacuum it all up with a vacuum just
make sure it doesn't get wet don't let
anyone there trampling in there like
keep a pet away for sure um and then get
a fresh carpet i love that i love it so
much because i'm always talking about in
our stands for stain segments please
don't push it down it's all about the
art of lifting
lifting
[Applause]
[Music]
and then i know this is something you're
obsessed with our stains like on clothes
and things this is my
why buy it when you can diy it that's
what i call it you can make your own
stain remover it's got a little bit of
that same soap i use a castile soap or a
dish soap whatever you want
baking soda that same ingredient we just
had hydrogen peroxide
and it all goes into a dark container
because these are all very active
ingredients
and then this is soy sauce
um right here on a sweater for me this
is very likely to be a stain on my
clothing and we're just gonna spray away
and be generous with this and this is
something where dish soap cuts grease
baking soda is a natural um cleaning
agent hydrogen peroxide bubbles
and lifts
everything up lift it
don't push on it which is the magic and
by the way you can find these online
these are little if you want it to go
version you just sell this little to go
pen it's refillable
rub it in
you know if you have like a little stain
right here where did you find that
online you can find these anywhere
online these are these are fantastic go
to the drewberrymarshow.com we'll tell
you where to get them
and i'll be ordering one right alongside
of you
it's like it really this really does
work
[Music]
you